It's peak pollination season, and my business is scaling fast. To keep the nectar flowing, I need a phone plan with top priority data speeds. That's why I chose Google Fi Wireless. My connections stay strong even when the hive is buzzing. Plus, unlimited plans started $35 a month. Now that's a deal that doesn't stay. Explore Google Fi Wireless plans today. Plus taxes and government fees.
现在是授粉高峰期，我的业务正在快速扩张。为了保持花蜜源源不断，我需要一个拥有顶级优先数据速度的手机套餐。这就是我选择 Google Fi Wireless 的原因。即使在蜂巢最繁忙的时候，我的连接依然稳固。此外，无限流量套餐每月仅需 35 美元起。这可是一个不会一直有的优惠。立即探索 Google Fi Wireless 套餐。另需缴纳税费和政府费用。
Google Fi Wireless is not subject to data traffic deprioritization during times of high network usage. relationships are essential to our health and happiness. But what happens when people find it difficult to feel secure, safe, and supported in their closest relationships with partners, friends, or family? Today we're going to talk with the psychologist who studies attachment theory about how our early and ongoing life experiences shape our later bonds with others. Why do some people find it easier to navigate close relationships than others? If you or your partner tend to feel anxious or insecure in your relationship, what can you do to change that? And what happens when attachment goes awry as in abusive or violent relationships? Welcome to Speaking of Psychology, the flagship podcast
Google Fi Wireless 在网络高负载时段不受数据流量降速限制。人际关系对我们的健康和幸福至关重要。但是，当人们在与伴侣、朋友或家人的亲密关系中难以感到安全、稳妥和支持时，会发生什么呢？今天，我们将与一位研究依恋理论的心理学家探讨我们早期和持续的生活经历如何塑造我们后来与他人的纽带。为什么有些人比其他人更容易处理亲密关系？如果你或你的伴侣在关系中容易感到焦虑或不安，你可以做些什么来改变这种情况？当依恋关系出现问题（例如在虐待或暴力关系中）时，又会发生什么？欢迎收听《心理学谈话》，这是美国心理学会的旗舰播客，
of the American Psychological Association that examines the links between psychological science and everyday life. I'm Kim Mills. My guest today is Dr. Jimena Ariaga, a professor of psychological sciences at Purdue University. She studies close relationship bonds, how they help people thrive within and beyond their relationships, but also how some bonds can cause considerable pain and harm. She's published dozens of peer-reviewed studies, and her research has been funded by the National Science Foundation, the National Institute of Mental Health, and other organizations. Dr. Ariaga has been recognized for her research and teaching with awards from Purdue and from the Society for Personality and Social psychology. Dr. Ariaga, thank you for joining me today. Thank you, Kim. It's really a pleasure to be
旨在探讨心理科学与日常生活之间的联系。我是金·米尔斯。我今天的嘉宾是普渡大学心理科学教授吉梅娜·阿里亚加博士。她研究亲密关系纽带，探讨这些纽带如何帮助人们在关系内外茁壮成长，同时也研究某些纽带如何造成巨大的痛苦和伤害。她发表了数十项同行评审研究，她的研究获得了美国国家科学基金会、美国国家心理健康研究所和其他组织的支持。阿里亚加博士凭借其研究和教学工作获得了普渡大学和人格与社会心理学学会颁发的奖项。阿里亚加博士，感谢您今天加入我的节目。谢谢你，金。今天能在这里与你交流，
here with you today. Let's start, as we often do with this podcast, with a definition. What is attachment or attachment style, and how many types of attachments are there? So an attachment orientation is simply a way of characterizing or describing how comfortable, how it ease, really how secure We are around others, especially in social contexts that will activate risk, will feel like they have red flags in them in terms of how we're going to be treated by others. So a classic example might be a child who's in the first day at a new school and they're going to enter the lunchroom. You know, we'd all feel pretty nervous about that, but there are going to be variations across people. people will differ in how they react to that situation. So in terms of styles, the popular media often will recognize four styles, a secure attachment,
我感到非常荣幸。我们像往常一样，从定义开始吧。什么是依恋或依恋类型？依恋类型有多少种？依恋取向其实就是一种描述我们在他人面前感到多么舒适、自在，或者说多么有安全感的方式，特别是在那些会引发风险、在对待我们的方式上可能存在“危险信号”的社交环境中。一个典型的例子可能是孩子第一天上新学校，他们要走进食堂。我们都会对此感到相当紧张，但不同的人会有所差异。人们对这种情况的反应各不相同。就类型而言，大众媒体通常会识别出四种类型：安全型依恋、
an anxious or preoccupied attachment, a dismissive avoidant or somewhat detached attachment style, and a fearful avoidant or somewhat disorganized attachment style. But really what we're talking about here are signature responses that will reflect variations in two things. Attachment anxiety and attachment avoidance. So we can place people in terms of where they are in those two dimensions. And certainly variations on those dimensions are useful for predicting a lot of things. What we think is going to happen, what we expect when we enter social situations. situations, what we pay attention to and what we perceive and how we make sense and interpret things
焦虑型或痴迷型依恋、回避型或疏离型依恋，以及恐惧型或混乱型依恋。但我们真正讨论的是反映两种维度差异的标志性反应：依恋焦虑和依恋回避。因此，我们可以根据人们在这两个维度上的位置对他们进行定位。当然，这些维度的变化对于预测很多事情都很有用。比如我们认为会发生什么，当我们进入社交场合时我们期待什么，我们关注什么，我们感知什么，以及我们如何理解和解读事物，
and certainly how we respond, how we react to them. What's the ideology of this? I mean, how do you learn an attachment style? Where does it come from in your life? Is it something that you learn as a child? Does it vary throughout your life? Are there any biological components? Yeah. Historically attachment theories have focused very much on the nurture side of it, nature, nurture debate. In the last 10 years, we're learning much more about biological underpinnings, especially with respect to attachment anxiety. But we can explain a lot of how people manifest a certain signature pattern, especially in their relationships, by just looking at their history. So we can go way back in history to their infancy, certainly attachment bonds begin from the moment we're born.
当然还有我们如何回应、如何对它们做出反应。这背后的意识形态是什么？我的意思是，你是如何习得一种依恋类型的？它在你的生活中从何而来？这是你小时候学到的吗？它会随着你的生活而改变吗？有生物学成分吗？是的。从历史上看，依恋理论非常关注“后天”这一面，即先天与后天的争论。在过去的 10 年里，我们对生物学基础了解得更多了，特别是在依恋焦虑方面。但我们只需观察人们的历史，就能解释他们为何在关系中表现出某种特定的模式。我们可以追溯到他们的婴儿期，依恋纽带当然是从我们出生那一刻起就开始了。
You know, so attachment bonds are something that we've evolved to have. Mammals need caregivers, mammals signal when they need something. And, you know, baby mammals tend to be pretty cute, so they also tend to evoke a lot of love and care. And, you know, all of that has the function of helping them survive. That is part of the attachment system that Bolby, John Bowlby, described. Now, as we fast forward, when we get into adulthood, there are traces of some stable tendencies. It could be stable ways of interpreting red flags, things like that. But it's our relationship history that's going to matter the most there.
你知道，依恋纽带是我们进化而来的产物。哺乳动物需要照顾者，哺乳动物在需要什么时会发出信号。而且，你知道，幼年哺乳动物通常非常可爱，所以它们也往往能激发出大量的爱和关怀。所有这些都有助于它们生存。这就是约翰·鲍尔比所描述的依恋系统的一部分。现在，快进到成年期，我们会发现一些稳定倾向的痕迹。这可能是解读危险信号的稳定方式等等。但最重要的是我们的关系史。
How have we been treated by past partners? How we've been treated by close others? Do we feel generally loved or do we feel like we've got a lot of work to do? Do we feel like there are danger signs all over the place? And can you have different attachment styles depending on the person you're relating to? Absolutely. In terms of styles, when we talk about styles, you know, it's a secure style as someone who generally is very comfortable around their relationship partners.
我们过去是如何被伴侣对待的？我们是如何被亲近的人对待的？我们通常感到被爱，还是觉得有很多工作要做？我们是否觉得到处都是危险信号？你是否会根据与之交往的人的不同而有不同的依恋类型？当然。就类型而言，当我们谈论类型时，安全型是指那些在关系伴侣面前通常感到非常自在的人。
They tend to expect, all things being equal, they don't expect. that they're going to be loved and valued, that they'll develop trust. They feel okay depending on that person, and they don't mind if that person depends on them. When there is a problem or a crisis or issue that comes up, they certainly respond with anger, with the things that most people respond with, but they don't overreact. They also don't underreact and shut down. So they hunker down and they work the problem. Now, that would be great if all our relationships were like that,
在一切条件相同的情况下，他们往往不会预期自己会被爱和被重视，他们会建立信任。他们觉得依赖那个人没问题，也不介意那个人依赖他们。当出现问题、危机或争议时，他们当然会以愤怒等大多数人的反应方式来回应，但他们不会反应过度。他们也不会反应不足而封闭自己。他们会沉下心来解决问题。如果我们的所有关系都是这样，那该多好，
but not all of them are like that. If I'm paired with someone who frankly flirts a lot with other people where I'm constantly seeing these signs that maybe they're not as committed as I want them to be, that's going to start to set off these red flags, and that's going to reinforce a more anxious attachment orientation. And so when people feel a lot of attachment anxiety, they're worried. They're worried. And this really is what fits the classic thing that comes to mind when we say someone's insecure.
但并非所有关系都是如此。如果我的伴侣经常与他人调情，而我不断看到这些迹象，表明他们可能不像我希望的那样忠诚，这就会开始触发这些危险信号，并强化一种更焦虑的依恋取向。因此，当人们感到强烈的依恋焦虑时，他们会感到担忧。他们非常担忧。这确实符合我们说某人“缺乏安全感”时想到的典型情况。
You know, they're overly worried. They seem like they're monitoring everything. Those are signs that in the past, that's what I had to do to protect myself. So I may have become pretty preoccupied with what was happening in my relationship because I want it to work. And yet my partner doesn't seem to be there with me at every step. I might become overly sensitive to problems. So even though in a new relationship, there's nothing to worry about, I may overinterpret signs that there's a problem and create mountains out of mole hills.
你知道，他们过度担忧。他们看起来好像在监控一切。这些迹象表明，在过去，为了保护自己，我不得不这样做。所以我可能变得非常关注关系中发生的事情，因为我希望它能成功。然而，我的伴侣似乎并没有在每一步都与我同步。我可能会对问题变得过度敏感。所以，即使在一段新的关系中，根本没有什么可担心的，我也可能会过度解读那些表明有问题存在的迹象，从而小题大做。
I might become very jealous easily and overly protective. And the other thing with attachment anxiety is that when a problem does arise, these are individuals who spiral in their negative emotions and catastrophes and really have trouble stepping back and being able to see the situation more objectively. They tend to interpret all of that strife and problem as being their own deficiency and a reflection of their own unworthiness or lack of value in some way.
我可能会变得很容易嫉妒并过度保护。依恋焦虑的另一面是，当问题确实出现时，这些人会陷入负面情绪和灾难化的漩涡中，很难退后一步客观地看待情况。他们倾向于将所有的冲突和问题解释为自己的缺陷，并将其视为自己缺乏价值或价值感不足的反映。
So that's one type, and then another type is attachment avoidance. And here the key thing is where as anxiously attach people are visibly insecure, avoidantly attach people will mask their concerns. They suppress their negative emotions. They become quite uncomfortable when a partner wants more emotional intimacy. They don't want to depend on others. They don't want others to depend on them. That's this kind of a hassle. They bulk at neediness. They value self-reliance. And then when there's a problem, when there is a conflict of some kind, Whereas anxious people put their emotions into high gear, they have what's called a hyperactivated response.
这就是一种类型，另一种是依恋回避。这里的关键在于，焦虑型依恋的人表现出明显的不安全感，而回避型依恋的人会掩盖他们的担忧。他们压抑自己的负面情绪。当伴侣想要更多的情感亲密时，他们会感到非常不舒服。他们不想依赖他人，也不想让别人依赖他们。这被视为一种麻烦。他们排斥依赖感。他们重视自力更生。当出现问题或某种冲突时，焦虑型的人会将情绪调至高档，产生所谓的“过度激活”反应。
Avoidant people will suppress and withdraw. They go into low gear and do what's called a deactivated response. So we see anxious people digging deeper into a problem, not letting go. We see avoiding people looking for the nearest exit running out and just assume never like, I never want to think about that again. Can we just move on to that? So the problem, as he just noted, is it's not necessarily the case that all relationships warrant insecurity. So if I had a series of relationships that made me pretty anxious,
回避型的人会压抑并退缩。他们进入低档，产生所谓的“去激活”反应。所以我们看到焦虑型的人深入挖掘问题，不肯放手。我们看到回避型的人寻找最近的出口逃跑，并假设“我再也不想考虑这个问题了”。我们能直接跳过吗？所以，正如他刚才指出的，问题在于，并非所有关系都必然导致不安全感。如果我经历了一系列让我感到非常焦虑的关系，
but then I enter a relationship with a pretty secure partner and someone who is very trustworthy, it's going to take some time for me to overcome it. And I may not be able to overcome it. I'm going to carry that history with me. And I am probably going to cause some problems in that relationship. going to be demanding a lot about my partner's commitment and showing me that they're faithful and showing me these things. That, you know, that's kind of exhausting. Partners get a little bit tired of that. And then you could say the same for avoidance, how that becomes unadaptive in a relationship where your partner actually is quite trustworthy. Attachment theory has a fairly long history in psychology. Can you talk a little bit about that? How did this whole
但随后我进入了一段与一个相当安全、非常值得信赖的伴侣的关系，我需要一些时间来克服它。而且我可能无法克服它。我会带着那段历史。我可能会在那段关系中制造一些问题。我会对伴侣的承诺提出很多要求，让他们向我证明他们是忠诚的。这让人感到精疲力竭。伴侣会对此感到厌倦。对于回避型的人来说，在伴侣实际上非常值得信赖的关系中，这种行为也会变得不适应。依恋理论在心理学中有着相当长的历史。你能谈谈这个吗？整个理论是如何
theory arise? So I mentioned John Bulby very briefly before. And, you know, John Bolby was anithologist. So he was studying animal behavior. And his observations were based on those infant mammals, you know, the infant kittens. And he didn't study kittens. But, but, you know, those behaviors that are universal in mammals. So these attachment processes, this idea that, you know, we need others. We need others. This is, this is not some modern, you know, conception. This is not sort of like a popular. This is pretty foundational. And Bolby, well, was super at laying out these normative processes that mammals seem to undergo as they seek assistance and support from others and others develop caregiving systems to provide that support.
产生的？我之前简要提到了约翰·鲍尔比。约翰·鲍尔比是一位动物行为学家。所以他研究的是动物行为。他的观察基于那些幼年哺乳动物，你知道，幼猫。他没有研究猫，但那些在哺乳动物中普遍存在的行为。所以这些依恋过程，这种我们需要他人的想法，这不是什么现代概念。这也不是什么大众化的东西。这是相当基础的。鲍尔比非常擅长阐述哺乳动物在寻求他人帮助和支持时所经历的这些规范性过程，而他人则发展出照顾系统来提供这种支持。
From mythology, we jump over to child development, where Mary Ainsworth took this a step further by saying, not all of us have the same experiences. So based on our personal histories, we're going to see some differences. And she identified very coherent signature patterns, individual differences that reflect insecurity. So it was Mary Ainsworth who really developed this idea of insecure types. From there we jump to social psychology, to the late 80s where Phil Schaber worked with Cindy Hazan and published several papers, but one particular one, very influential, that made a strong case for understanding. understanding romantic bonds in terms of these attachment processes.
从动物行为学，我们跳跃到儿童发展领域，玛丽·安斯沃思更进一步指出，我们并非都有相同的经历。根据我们的个人历史，我们会看到一些差异。她识别出了非常连贯的标志性模式，即反映不安全感的个体差异。所以是玛丽·安斯沃思真正发展了这种“不安全类型”的概念。从那里我们跳跃到社会心理学，到了 80 年代末，菲尔·谢弗与辛迪·哈赞合作发表了几篇论文，其中一篇特别有影响力，它有力地论证了从这些依恋过程的角度来理解
And that launched thousands of studies. What I should say is Phil Schaeber actually met with personality psychologist Mario Mickelencer. So it was that pairing that launched, you know, the thousand studies that defined the field. I mean, they have arguably one of the most prolific partnerships in psychological science. I call them the Watson and Crick of Adult Social Bonds. Like, you know, they're the thing. right there. And then there have been others too. I mean, Chris Frailey studied with Phil Schaver and
浪漫纽带。这引发了数千项研究。我应该说，菲尔·谢弗实际上遇到了人格心理学家马里奥·米库林瑟。正是这种组合开启了定义该领域的数千项研究。他们可以说是心理科学中最富有成效的合作伙伴之一。我称他们为成人社会纽带领域的“沃森和克里克”。他们就是那个领域的权威。当然还有其他人。克里斯·弗雷利曾师从菲尔·谢弗，
Chris Fraley has been very influential in mapping these two adult attachment dimensions, anxiety and avoidance and what it means to vary on those two sides of it. That brings us up to about 2015. I would not necessarily put myself in this line of history among these luminaries, but what we did start doing in 2015 was asking, what about this? insecure still. Like, we know so much about insecurity. We know so much about what anxious individuals do, how they behave, what it means for their relationships, avoidance, and so forth. But can we change that? You know, can we help people become more secure? And that's what got us thinking about that. And what we're seeing is a lot of people actually want to answer that question.
克里斯·弗雷利在绘制这两个成人依恋维度（焦虑和回避）以及在这两个维度上变化意味着什么方面非常有影响力。这把我们带到了 2015 年左右。我未必会把自己放在这些杰出人物的历史行列中，但我们确实在 2015 年开始问：关于这种不安全感，我们还能做什么？我们对不安全感了解得太多了。我们非常了解焦虑个体做什么、他们如何表现、这对他们的关系意味着什么，以及回避型等等。但我们能改变它吗？我们能帮助人们变得更安全吗？这就是让我们开始思考这个问题的原因。我们看到很多人实际上都想回答这个问题。
So what got you interested in studying this particular aspect of psychology? When I entered graduate school, I picked the person not the topic, my late advisor. Carol Rusbold was a formidable, fabulous person, and I met her and said, I want to be like, like she is, you know, that's my model. And so that took me down the road of close relationships. We did not study attachment processes, but I did become very interested in this question of whether you can change stable tendencies. So I teamed up with another one of Carol Rusbold's students, Modoka Kumashiro. And early on, we actually had a whole great group. Eli Finkel was part of that group as well. And, you know, Medoka and I got very interested in this issue of how do people
是什么让你对心理学的这个特定方面产生了兴趣？当我进入研究生院时，我选择的是人而不是主题，我已故的导师卡罗尔·拉斯博尔德是一位令人敬畏、极好的人，我见到她后说，我想成为像她那样的人，那是我的榜样。这让我走上了研究亲密关系的道路。我们没有研究依恋过程，但我确实对“你是否能改变稳定倾向”这个问题产生了浓厚的兴趣。所以我与卡罗尔·拉斯博尔德的另一位学生小田冈熊代合作。早些时候，我们实际上有一个非常棒的团队。伊莱·芬克尔也是该小组成员。我和小田冈对人们如何
become more secure. What really got me interested in this was being an instructor. You know, I would teach a course on close relationships, and I would go over everything we knew about attachment styles and, you know, how anxious individuals really struggle in their relationships. And, you know, Kim, I'd look out into my students and I'd see these faces suddenly look super concerned and just distraught. And I was like, okay, those are the anxious. individuals in my group. And then I describe avoidance and how people sort of detach and shut down. And sure enough, I'd look in the audience and some students would be turning away and wanting to look at their phone and not having any of this. And I'm like, they're my avoidance, you know. And invariably
变得更安全这个问题非常感兴趣。真正让我感兴趣的是作为一名讲师。我会教授一门关于亲密关系的课程，我会回顾我们所知道的关于依恋类型的一切，以及焦虑个体在关系中是如何挣扎的。金，我会看着我的学生，看到这些面孔突然变得非常担忧和心烦意乱。我想，好吧，那些是我小组里的焦虑型个体。然后我描述回避型，以及人们如何疏离和封闭自己。果然，我会看向观众，一些学生会转过身去，想看手机，不想听这些。我想，他们是我的回避型学生。总是
some would come up to me after class and say, you know, am I due? Am I never going to have a decent relationship? And I thought, nah, come on, that can be, if it's situations, if it's certain moments, key moments that get people to turn to more security, that reinforce insecurity. Surely there must be moments, key salient moments that can reinforce more security. And that's what really got us studying that. Your summer starts now with Memorial Day deals
有人会在课后走过来问我：“我是不是完了？我永远不会有体面的关系了吗？”我想，不，别这样，如果情况是这样，如果某些时刻、关键时刻能让人们转向更安全的状态，从而强化不安全感，那么肯定也存在能强化安全感的关键时刻。这就是真正让我们开始研究它的原因。你的夏天从家得宝的阵亡将士纪念日促销开始。
at the Home Depot. It's time to fire up summer cookouts with the next grill, four-burner gas grill, on special buy for only $199 and entertain all season with the Hampton Bay West Grove seven-piece outdoor dining set for only $499. This Memorial Day get low prices guaranteed at the Home Depot. While supplies last, price invalid May 14th or May 27th. U.S. only exclusions apply. See Home Depot.com slash price match for details. You said this place was steps from the water. We just haven't found the steps yet.
是时候用 Next Grill 四头燃气烤架来开启夏季烧烤了，特价仅需 199 美元；用 Hampton Bay West Grove 七件套户外餐桌椅套装来招待整个季节的客人，仅需 499 美元。这个阵亡将士纪念日，在家得宝享受低价保证。售完即止，价格有效期为 5 月 14 日至 5 月 27 日。仅限美国，适用排除条款。详情请见 HomeDepot.com/pricematch。你说这个地方离水边只有几步之遥。我们只是还没找到那几步路。
How much did we save? Enough. Enough to get lost! Or you could book a stay with Hilton. Welcome to your oceanfront room. Just steps from the water. The Hilton sale is on now. Book on Hilton.com or the Hilton app
我们省了多少钱？足够了。足够去迷路了！或者你可以预订希尔顿酒店的住宿。欢迎来到你的海滨客房。离水边仅几步之遥。希尔顿促销活动现已开启。在 Hilton.com 或希尔顿应用程序上预订，
and save up to 20% to get the stay you expected. When you want savings, not surprises. It matters where you stay. Hilton, for the stay. For some of our listeners who might be just starting a relationship with someone, how can they tell what that other person's attachment style is and whether it's going to be compatible with their own? Compatibility is an interesting issue.
最高可享 8 折优惠，获得你期待的住宿体验。当你想要节省开支，而不是意外时，你住哪里很重要。希尔顿，为你而住。对于我们一些可能刚开始一段关系的人来说，他们如何判断对方的依恋类型，以及它是否与自己的兼容？兼容性是一个有趣的问题。
I mean, they can tell where there are sensitive spots with their partner. You know, we all at times will feel anxious, and we all at times will probably feel avoidance. So in that pairing, it's figuring out what am I doing that might trigger anxiety for my partner or might trigger avoidance for my partner. Now, there are also signs when my partner's having a bad day at work and they refuse to talk about it, that's avoidance.
我的意思是，他们可以判断伴侣的敏感点在哪里。我们所有人有时都会感到焦虑，有时也可能会感到回避。所以在这种配对中，关键在于弄清楚我正在做什么可能会触发伴侣的焦虑或回避。当然，当我的伴侣在工作中度过了糟糕的一天，却拒绝谈论它时，那就是回避。
Or my partner's having a bad day at work and they just cannot let it go. That's anxiety. And so those would be the kinds of signs that, again, that's sort of hyperactivated, overreacting, or deactivated, underreacting to stressful situations. But I think compatibility often just comes. comes down to that moment where you really want to be committed to this person. And you're getting signs that that person really wants to be committed to you. So at that point, no relationship
或者我的伴侣在工作中度过了糟糕的一天，却无法释怀。那就是焦虑。这些就是那种对压力情况过度激活、反应过度，或去激活、反应不足的迹象。但我认为兼容性通常归结为那个你真正想要对这个人做出承诺的时刻。而你得到的迹象表明，那个人也真的想对你做出承诺。所以在那一点上，没有一段关系
is perfect. You have to work things out. And I think there are ways to alleviate some anxieties and alleviate some avoidant tendencies in relationships. And what are some of those ways? That's a big question. That's a load of question. When Medoka and I started to ask this question of how might people become more secure, we wanted to study relationship bonds, one, because we knew about how those bonds work, and two, because relationship partners are really important attachment figures in adulthood. They're not the only ones. I think that others might have a close friend, sometimes a neighbor. There are a lot of close others who can be that attachment figure. Attachment figures can be really important in reinforcing security in two ways. The first way is we know that insecurities wreak havoc with relationships. When the anxious person, just all they want is to get their partner's commitment, but they demand too much, that has the self-reinforcing effect of pushing a partner away. When the voidant person seems way too detached and can't seem to commit,
是完美的。你必须解决问题。我认为在关系中，有一些方法可以缓解一些焦虑和回避倾向。有哪些方法？这是一个大问题。这是一个沉重的问题。当我和小田冈开始问“人们如何变得更安全”这个问题时，我们想研究关系纽带，第一，因为我们知道这些纽带是如何运作的，第二，因为关系伴侣是成年后非常重要的依恋对象。他们不是唯一的。我认为其他人可能有一个亲密朋友，有时是邻居。有很多亲近的人可以成为那个依恋对象。依恋对象在强化安全感方面非常重要，有两种方式。第一种方式是，我们知道不安全感会破坏关系。当焦虑型的人只是想得到伴侣的承诺，但要求太多时，这会产生将伴侣推开的自我强化效应。当回避型的人看起来太疏离且似乎无法做出承诺时，
that has the self-reinforcing effect of having a partner also pull away because they're seeing this go nowhere. So those insecurities that the first part is trying to mitigate the negative effects that they can have on relationships. What people feel really anxious, we were really interested in what we call soft strategies. And there's no mystery here. It's actually, to me, rather obvious at least. So partners can do a lot to mitigate another person. anxiety by providing lots of reassurance, lots of emotional reassurance, being a calming, soothing influence to try to diffuse some of those spiraling negative emotions, communicating really
这会产生让伴侣也退缩的自我强化效应，因为他们觉得这段关系没有未来。所以，第一部分是试图减轻这些不安全感对关系可能产生的负面影响。当人们感到非常焦虑时，我们对所谓的“软策略”非常感兴趣。这里没有什么神秘之处。对我来说，这至少是显而易见的。因此，伴侣可以通过提供大量的安慰、大量的情感安慰，成为一种冷静、舒缓的影响力，试图化解那些螺旋式上升的负面情绪，从而减轻另一个人的焦虑，并传达出非常
strong commitment. So a very effective response might be something like, I know this is really concerning. It makes sense that you're very worried. You don't want to belittle something. It makes sense that you're very worried. And hug, hug, kiss, kiss, touch, touch. And then at that point, you say something like, well, I'm with you 100%. Whatever you want to do, I will be right behind you. If you want help great, if you want to go solo, great. But we're going to get through this. And I don't want anything bad to happen to you. So we will work this problem. You know, that's a lot of reassurance right there. Now, note that there are two things about that response. The first thing, don't try that on an avoidant person. That's going to backfire. So they're very different strategies
坚定的承诺。所以一个非常有效的回应可能是这样的：“我知道这真的很令人担忧。你感到非常焦虑是有道理的。”你不想贬低某事。“你感到非常担忧是有道理的。”然后拥抱、亲吻、触摸。然后在那一点上，你说类似这样的话：“好吧，我 100% 支持你。无论你想做什么，我都会在你身后。如果你需要帮助，太好了；如果你想独自完成，也很好。但我们会度过难关的。我不希望你发生任何不好的事情。所以我们会解决这个问题。”你知道，那提供了很多安慰。注意，那个回应有两点。第一点，不要试图对回避型的人使用那种方法。那会适得其反。所以针对回避型的不安全感，有非常不同的策略
to use with an avoidant insecurity, and that's not always obvious to people. The second thing is that even though that puts a band-aid on the moment, okay, we saved the relationship in the moment, those responses are not getting at a telltale feature of attachment anxiety. That's a relatively negative mental model of oneself. You know, we have these certain critical mental representations. Our mental representation of ourself is really elaborate. It's a lifetime of experiences. So our mental model of ourself for anxious individuals tends to be characterized by low self-esteem, low self-worth, low self-efficacy. That's the real issue in attach. That's what sustains attachment anxiety. So to really change this over the longer term, a partner can do a second.
可以使用，这对人们来说并不总是显而易见的。第二点是，尽管这给当下贴上了一个创可贴，好吧，我们在当下挽救了这段关系，但这些回应并没有触及依恋焦虑的一个显著特征。那就是对自己相对负面的心理模型。你知道，我们有这些特定的关键心理表征。我们对自己的心理表征非常复杂。这是一生的经历。因此，对于焦虑个体来说，我们对自己的心理模型往往表现为低自尊、低自我价值感、低自我效能感。这是依恋中真正的问题。这就是维持依恋焦虑的原因。因此，要从长远来看真正改变这一点，伴侣可以做第二
type of thing. And that's to identify those situations that might revise that negative way of seeing oneself. Okay, so partner with an anxious individual might look for those confidence boosting moments. If their partner suddenly gets, and if their anxious person suddenly gets an award, a partner can capitalize on that. They could say, you know, I know you feel like anyone might have gotten this award because anxious individuals are notoriously bad at taking compliments, by the way. You can't just say, good job. You know, that's going to seem empty. But, you know, I know you feel like anyone could have gotten this award, but here's what I saw. I saw you work really hard every single weekend for this. I saw you be really dedicated to this. And sure, maybe others could have gotten
种事情。那就是识别那些可能修正这种负面自我认知的情况。好吧，与焦虑个体在一起的伴侣可能会寻找那些增强自信的时刻。如果他们的伴侣突然获得了一个奖项，伴侣可以利用这一点。他们可以说：“你知道，我知道你觉得任何人都能获得这个奖项。”顺便说一句，焦虑个体以不擅长接受赞美而闻名。你不能只说“干得好”。你知道，那看起来会很空洞。但是，“我知道你觉得任何人都能获得这个奖项，但我看到了什么。我看到你为了这个奖项每个周末都努力工作。我看到你对此非常投入。当然，也许其他人也能获得
it, but you got it. And I think this is important. And I think this is the start of something. I think you're on to something really important. Okay, so it's amplifying the moment and trying to get them to internalize it in some way. You know, I'm reminded of a friend of mine who, when she first entered academics, she just felt like she didn't belong. And her advisor immediately could stop a brilliant scholar and said, this is a great idea. You know, this is a really important idea. The more reinforcement she got for her ability and for her efficacy as a researcher, the more the social anxiety, do I belong and not just melted away. She wasn't as preoccupied with it. So it's boosting that model of self for anxious individuals. But it sounds a little bit like imposter syndrome
它，但你获得了。我认为这很重要。我认为这是某件事的开始。我认为你正在做一些非常重要的事情。”好吧，所以这是放大那个时刻，并试图让他们以某种方式内化它。你知道，我想起我的一个朋友，当她刚进入学术界时，她觉得她不属于那里。她的导师立刻就能阻止一位杰出的学者并说：“这是一个伟大的想法。这是一个非常重要的想法。”她对自己的能力和作为研究者的效能获得的肯定越多，那种社交焦虑——“我属于这里吗？”——就越融化。她不再那么纠结于此了。所以对于焦虑个体来说，这是在增强自我模型。但这听起来有点像冒名顶替综合症
might have been at play there as well, right? I mean, do these things relate to each other? Yes, they do. They do. And, you know, I think there's some lessons here. I've been in higher education now for 30 years. And, you know, before we talked about DEI, I was talking about inclusion. And the reason to talk about inclusion is because when people feel imposter syndrome in a work setting. If you can find what they're really good at and exploit that, like, you're really good at this. This is what you do really well. The other stuff will follow. The feeling excluded, all those things. Not always. There are some real barriers to feeling excluded. But a lot of that, the psychological feeling and not being included, it becomes secondary to the fact that, hey, I'm actually a rock star at
可能也在其中发挥了作用，对吧？我的意思是，这些事情有关联吗？是的，它们有关联。而且，我认为这里有一些教训。我在高等教育领域已经 30 年了。在谈论 DEI（多元、公平和包容）之前，我就在谈论包容。谈论包容的原因是，当人们在工作环境中感到冒名顶替综合症时，如果你能找到他们真正擅长的事情并加以利用，比如“你真的很擅长这个。这是你做得非常好的事情”，其他事情就会随之而来。那种被排斥的感觉，所有这些事情。并不总是这样。感到被排斥确实存在一些真正的障碍。但其中很多，那种心理上的感觉和没有被包容，变得次要于这样一个事实：嘿，我实际上是这方面的
this and I can do pretty well at this. And it's a way of overcoming that imposter's. syndrome. Do people who form bonds or get into relationships tend to have the same kind of attachment style? I mean, does like mate with like, so to speak? I wish I could answer that question with confidence. So there are historically some data on this suggesting that, yes, we tend to see secures with secures and insecure with insecures. And when we look at that insecure, insecure pattern, it's not uncommon to see avoidance with anxiety. And so immediately you're asking, well, which came first? Was it that an anxious person made the other one more avoidant? Or did the voided person make the other one more anxious? You know, which one came first? And that historically was also confounded with some gender
摇滚明星，我能做得很好。这是一种克服冒名顶替综合症的方法。形成纽带或进入关系的人是否倾向于拥有相同的依恋类型？我的意思是，所谓的“物以类聚”吗？我希望我能自信地回答这个问题。历史上确实有一些数据表明，是的，我们倾向于看到安全型与安全型在一起，不安全型与不安全型在一起。当我们观察那种“不安全型与不安全型”的模式时，看到回避型与焦虑型在一起并不罕见。所以你立刻会问，那么谁先开始的？是焦虑型的人让对方变得更回避了吗？还是回避型的人让对方变得更焦虑了？你知道，哪个先开始的？这在历史上也与一些性别
patterns. So when you look at the clinical psych literature on marital dynamics, you know, the classic pattern of demand withdrawal, that has anxiety avoidance written all over it. Now, the reason I'm tentative in saying that's still true is because we are seeing a lot of attachment anxiety right now. Now, we're also seeing a lot of anxiety, period. And I think those two are related. So we're seeing many more couples where they're both anxiously attached, and it's hard to disambiguate whether the origins are these experiences with social bonds and how one was treated previously by important others versus just general anxiety from social media and all the things in life that are causing a lot of anxiety. You also study abusive and violent relationships. What role does
模式混淆了。所以当你查看关于婚姻动态的临床心理学文献时，那种经典的“需求-撤退”模式，上面写满了焦虑和回避。现在，我之所以对说这仍然是事实持保留态度，是因为我们现在看到了大量的依恋焦虑。现在，我们也看到了大量的焦虑。我认为这两者是相关的。所以我们看到更多的伴侣双方都是焦虑型依恋，很难分辨其根源是这些社会纽带的经历以及之前重要他人对待他们的方式，还是仅仅来自社交媒体和生活中导致大量焦虑的所有事情的普遍焦虑。你也研究虐待和暴力关系。依恋在这些关系中扮演什么角色，
attachment play in these relationships, and what can that tell us about how to help people who are in those relationships? Yes, I think that violence and attachment can have an interplay of an association. So I think they can go both directions. There's some data from long ago that would look at how perpetrators who exhibited this anxiously attached style would be overly controlling and very jealous and lash out. there's still evidence of that, but perpetration is multiply determined. And so there are a lot of perpetrators that aren't at all anxiously attached. On the receiving end of violence, and I know
这能告诉我们如何帮助处于这些关系中的人吗？是的，我认为暴力和依恋之间可能存在相互作用。所以我认为它们可以双向发展。很久以前有一些数据观察到，表现出这种焦虑型依恋风格的施暴者会过度控制、非常嫉妒并大发雷霆。仍然有这方面的证据，但施暴行为是由多种因素决定的。所以有很多施暴者根本不是焦虑型依恋。在遭受暴力的一方，我知道
there are lots of data on how violence is by direction and so forth, I think there's a methodological artifact there and how we study violence. And I think that when you start tracing back to the origins of that relationship, you probably will see one person perpetrating violence a little bit more than the other one and the other one reciprocating. So when people are on the receiving end of violence, we just published a paper showing how those experiences with abuse will reinforce avoidance, how the adaptive, rational thing is to shut down emotionally because this is an untenable situation and it is too painful to remain engaged. So we do see these links between a person's attachment style or orientation and their experience
有很多关于暴力是双向的等等的数据，我认为在研究暴力的方法上存在一种方法论的人为因素。我认为当你开始追溯那段关系的起源时，你可能会看到一个人施暴的频率比另一个人高一点，而另一个人在进行报复。所以当人们处于遭受暴力的一方时，我们刚刚发表了一篇论文，展示了那些虐待经历如何强化回避，如何理性的适应方式是在情感上封闭自己，因为这是一种站不住脚的情况，保持参与太痛苦了。所以我们确实看到了一个人的依恋类型或取向与他们经历
is either perpetrating or being on the receiving end of violence. But they're difficult that we need, when we think about them, we have to kind of go in and pick specific behaviors like when a partner is engaging in abusive, verbal abusive or is what we're likely to see. Or when a partner feels jealousy, probably that's being driven by their own attachment. in history and so forth. So we just need a little bit of precision in that literature. One of your studies had to do with how young people in abusive or controlling relationships felt after they broke up, what did you find and were some of those results surprising?
施暴或遭受暴力之间的这些联系。但它们很困难，我们需要在思考它们时，深入挖掘具体的行为，比如当伴侣进行言语虐待时，这是我们可能看到的。或者当伴侣感到嫉妒时，这很可能是由他们自己的依恋历史等驱动的。所以我们只需要在文献中保持一点精确度。你的研究中有一项是关于处于虐待或控制关系中的年轻人分手后的感受，你发现了什么？其中一些结果令人惊讶吗？
Yeah. I'm thinking of work that I've done with Win Goodfriend, and something that happens in abusive relationships when it tends to be more one-sided, or at least in its origins, it was more one-sided where a person was a victim of very abusive behavior. There's a loss of self. So there's a sense that I don't matter that much and people just forget about themselves. And let me give you an example of this. I remember being part of a support group at one point where there was an activity that involved, hey, let's talk about what you like to make for dinner. What's your favorite meal for dinner. And one person said, well, you know, my husband loves it when I'm a chicken catch a door. Like, that's great. We all have chicken catch a door. What do you like for dinner? What's your
是的。我想到我与温·古德弗兰德所做的工作，在虐待关系中，当它往往更倾向于单方面时，或者至少在起源上，它更倾向于单方面，即一个人是极度虐待行为的受害者。会有一种自我的丧失。所以有一种“我并不重要”的感觉，人们只是忘记了自己。让我给你举个例子。我记得有一次参加一个支持小组，其中有一个活动涉及：“嘿，我们来谈谈你喜欢做什么晚餐。你最喜欢的晚餐是什么？”一个人说：“嗯，你知道，我丈夫喜欢我做鸡肉卡恰托雷。”“太棒了。我们都吃鸡肉卡恰托雷。你喜欢什么晚餐？你最
favorite? Well, my kids love it when I blah, blah, blah. So there was this sense that I am not here. And that loss of self is a sign of having been controlled and belittled and humiliated repeatedly for a long time. That's a rational response. If I'm in an abusive relationship and I don't see a way out, and I don't mean just financial dependence, I mean emotional commitment as well, psychological dependence. So if I'm in a long time relationship, I may have a job, I may be able to make it fine on myself. We have a lifetime together. We've got kids together. We've got plans for the future. We have our entire networks together. I saw myself with this person. I know that when they're not abusive, they can be abused.
喜欢的？”“嗯，我的孩子们喜欢我做这个那个。”所以有一种感觉是“我不在那里”。那种自我的丧失是长期被控制、贬低和羞辱的迹象。这是一种理性的反应。如果我处于一段虐待关系中，我看不到出路，我指的不仅仅是经济依赖，还有情感承诺，心理依赖。所以如果我处于一段长期的关系中，我可能有工作，我可能能够自食其力。我们有一生的共同经历。我们有孩子。我们有未来的计划。我们有共同的社交网络。我看到自己和这个人在一起。我知道当他们不施暴时，他们可以是
good person. So it's a very complicated thing to undo. And when a person's not ready to undo it, the rational response is to reinterpret the violence, to say, well, it's not so bad. There are reasons behind it. It's just defiable and so forth. All of that leads to one putting oneself in where I don't matter. I'm in the very back of the line. When people leave an abusive relationship, only then do they look back with a different lens. And then, they see, ah, I understand that when she was being abusive toward me, I was ignoring it. I was denying it. I was reinterpreting it. And I couldn't see that in the moment. No matter what my friends would say to me, I couldn't see it, which, by the way, that's why it's very difficult to intervene in this.
一个好人。所以这是一个非常复杂的问题，很难撤销。当一个人还没有准备好撤销它时，理性的反应是重新解读暴力，说：“嗯，没那么糟。这背后是有原因的。这只是可以辩解的，等等。”所有这些都导致一个人把自己放在“我不重要”的位置。我排在队伍的最末端。当人们离开一段虐待关系时，只有那时他们才会用不同的视角回顾过去。然后，他们看到：“啊，我明白了，当她对我施暴时，我在忽视它。我在否认它。我在重新解读它。”而在当时，我无法看到这一点。无论我的朋友对我怎么说，我都看不到，顺便说一句，这就是为什么干预这一点非常困难。
Very well-intentioned friends will say something, but it's falling on deaf years when a person is still very committed. Now I see it. That's the moment to start to bolster that sense of self again. That's the moment to start to build that sense and self-ful. So find a hobby. How did it go with your hobby? Wow, that's really cool what you did. How did you crochet that? Anything that starts to give that person a sense of self-agency, this is what I like.
非常善意的朋友会说些什么，但当一个人仍然非常投入时，这些话就成了耳边风。现在我看到了。那是再次支撑那种自我感的时刻。那是开始建立那种感觉和自我感的时刻。所以找个爱好。“你的爱好进行得怎么样了？哇，你做的那个真的很酷。你是怎么钩织那个的？”任何能开始给那个人一种自我代理感的事情——“这是我喜欢的，
This is what I want and this is what matters to me. What are you studying now and what are the big questions that still remain to be answered in this field? So I come back to the attachment work because I think that that is so universal. we haven't solved this issue of how do we help people become more secure. Now, I think any mental health experts, so counselors, anyone who's working in the mental health space has probably solved it and can work with someone carefully along the lines of the late Sue Johnson's work on emotion-focused therapy. But that's a very long process of trying to overcome insecurities.
这是我想要的，这是对我重要的事情。”你现在在研究什么？这个领域还有哪些重大问题有待回答？所以我回到了依恋研究，因为我认为它是如此普遍。我们还没有解决如何帮助人们变得更安全这个问题。现在，我认为任何心理健康专家，也就是咨询师，任何在心理健康领域工作的人可能都已经解决了这个问题，并且可以沿着已故苏·约翰逊的情绪聚焦疗法的工作，仔细地与某人合作。但这是一个试图克服不安全感的漫长过程。
And let's face it's very expensive process too. And not everyone can afford the time or money to do that kind of work. What I would love to do is to be able to provide people with information that might help. Here's the thing. Like if I want to change, like let's say, I'm really anxiously attached. I want to become more secure. Great. Now I'm going to set out to do it.
而且我们要面对现实，这也是一个非常昂贵的过程。并不是每个人都有时间和金钱去做那种工作。我非常希望能为人们提供一些可能有帮助的信息。问题在于，比如如果我想改变，假设我是一个非常焦虑型依恋的人，我想变得更安全，这很好，现在我要开始行动了。
That's half the story. I may have the volition. I may have the will to do it. But I'm not sure what to do. I really don't know. You know, like I just said, the kind of responses for avoidant reactions are very different from the kinds of responses one might have for anxious reactions in terms of effective responses. So I'd love to have information that people can adapt to their own lives.
但这只是故事的一半。我可能有意愿，我有动力去做，但我不知道该怎么做。我真的不知道。就像我刚才说的，对于回避型反应的应对方式，与焦虑型反应的有效应对方式是非常不同的。所以我很希望能提供一些人们可以应用到自己生活中的信息。
When we talk about safe strategies for anxious individuals or soft strategies for avoidant individuals, which I didn't get into that much, but we've written about that. It's not cut and dry, I do one, two, three. it's something that a person has to be ready to adapt and know how to adapt, have the skill to adapt to their own life and their own relationships. So I'm really interested in doing good science that provides an answer to that. How can people adapt these things to their own lives? We've done some experimental work, but it is really difficult work. Well, it sounds like there's still a lot to learn than in attachment theory.
当我们谈论焦虑型个体的安全策略，或者回避型个体的软策略时——虽然我没有深入探讨，但我们已经写过相关内容——这并不是一成不变的“一二三”步骤。这是一个人必须准备好去适应、知道如何适应，并具备将其应用到自己生活和人际关系中技能的过程。所以我非常有兴趣进行严谨的科学研究，来回答这个问题：人们如何将这些东西应用到自己的生活中？我们做了一些实验性工作，但这确实非常困难。听起来依恋理论还有很多东西需要学习。
I think there is. I think there is. It's an exciting field. I really respect the people who have been forerunners in this field. I think it's great work. And, you know, the thing Kim, about relationship science is I'm never sure if I should tell people I'm a relationship scientist. I mean, the first reaction I always get is like, oh, you must be analyzing my relationship. And I always joke back like, in fact, I am. You're not doing so well. I mean, I don't say that to them. But, you know, it sounds a little bit fluffy and light. And the reality is that relationship scientists have studied and identified some pretty core principles about getting along with others. And I think the lessons extrapolate to societal problems and societal issues and community problems.
我认为确实如此。这是一个令人兴奋的领域。我非常尊重这个领域的先驱们，我认为他们的工作非常出色。金，关于关系科学，我从不确定是否应该告诉别人我是关系科学家。我的意思是，我得到的第一反应总是：“哦，你一定在分析我的关系。”我总是开玩笑说：“事实上，我确实在分析，而且你表现得不太好。”当然，我不会真的对他们这么说。但这听起来有点轻浮。但现实是，关系科学家已经研究并确定了一些关于如何与他人相处的核心原则。我认为这些经验教训可以推演到社会问题、社会议题和社区问题上。
And so I think there's a lot to learn there. And I think that there's a lot that we've learned that we can certainly apply to a lot of the issues and problems that we're confronting right now. Dr. Ariaga, I want to thank you for joining me today. It's been really interesting. Thank you. Thank you very much. It was a pleasure being here. You can find previous episodes of Speaking of Psychology on our website at speakingof psychology.org
所以我认为这里有很多值得学习的地方。我认为我们已经学到的很多东西，完全可以应用到我们目前面临的许多议题和问题中。阿里亚加博士，感谢您今天加入我的节目，这真的非常有趣。谢谢。非常感谢，很高兴能来到这里。您可以在我们的网站 speakingofpsychology.org 上找到《心理学谈话》往期的节目。
or on Apple, Spotify, YouTube, or wherever you get your podcasts. And if you like what you've heard, please follow us and leave a review. If you have comments or ideas for future podcasts, you can email us at speaking of psychology at APA.org. Speaking of psychology is produced by Lee Wyerman. Thank you for listening to the American Psychological Association. I'm Kim Mills. Enjoy more ways to save at Ralph's, like low prices in every aisle.
或者在 Apple、Spotify、YouTube 或任何您获取播客的地方收听。如果您喜欢我们的节目，请关注我们并留下评论。如果您对未来的播客有任何意见或想法，可以发送电子邮件至 speakingofpsychology@apa.org。《心理学谈话》由李·怀尔曼制作。感谢收听美国心理学会的节目，我是金·米尔斯。在 Ralph's 享受更多省钱方式，比如每个过道的低价商品。
And when you download the Ralph's app, you can clip and save more with digital coupons every week. Plus, you can earn fuel points to save up to $1 per gallon at the pump. At Ralph's, you can enjoy more ways to save and more rewards every time you shop. So it's always easy to save big every day with savings and rewards. Ralph's SoCal for over 150 years, savings may vary by state. Fuel restrictions apply. Seasite for details. There aren't comments yet for this episode. Click on any sentence in the transcript to leave a comment.
下载 Ralph's 应用程序，您每周都可以通过数字优惠券剪辑并节省更多费用。此外，您还可以赚取燃油积分，在加油站每加仑最多可节省 1 美元。在 Ralph's，您每次购物都能享受更多省钱方式和更多奖励。因此，通过这些优惠和奖励，每天都能轻松省下一大笔钱。Ralph's SoCal 超过 150 年，节省金额可能因州而异。燃油限制适用，详情请见网站。本集目前还没有评论。点击转录稿中的任何句子即可发表评论。